so my producers put together some of
their favorite memes and then demanded
that I react to them so we shall do that
now we'll see how this goes
everyone at the store they had butter
today blessed be the fruit praise be not
not not there no no no no me watching my
girlfriend breathe after three weeks of
listening to her talk and watch her
stupid shows during Kourtney okay I
don't even know that the meme is that
good just the picture of Christopher
Walken is that good next meme okay okay
the jugs otic that's that's not bad at
all
jugs out I can what's it what's the name
of the lady Carol Carol Baskin yeah
that's that's that is not bad at all
actually that's quite good boss you free
to video chat me Culkin yeah that's that
that's that's a solid one I like this
one this one this one is good and that
is also true very very true me in 20
years when a Charmin commercial comes on
I having war flashbacks because of all
the toilet paper shortages yeah I like
the bear picture there is very so that's
good these are good these are good guys
well well done Netflix 98% match me and
then yeah that's exactly right because
everything on Netflix that Netflix made
is an IBA percent match and so it's
something unbelievably dumb that I would
never want to watch I can't remember the
last time Netflix is like here's a
recommended match I'm like great idea
Netflix nope help me obi-wan Kenobi no
written indirection okay that that's
that's funny
okay that's that's funny Rian Johnson
overrated Rian Johnson literally just
walked around my house for five minutes
finding tiny things that are enough to
make a parents nap yeah that's fair
although honestly none of these are the
things that would make a parent snap
right the stuff that makes a parents nap
is like the kid spills on the floor
there's a mess on the floor
like are you kidding two darts on the
carpet like to to nerf nerf gun darts on
the carpet that's that's called like a
clean house right there a glass not on a
coaster I don't know where you're living
ritzy fancy-pants I know it's more like
vomit on the vomit on the floors is the
stuff that make
parent nuts poop on the toilet like that
come on let's get real about what what
parents actually go through here the
last molecule of serotonin to my brain
doing its best to make sure I fare okay
social distancing okay a video well it's
a lot of memes guys that is a cat
speaking with a southern accent not a
cat guy all right so my four-year-old
nephew asked me to draw him Harry Potter
the excitedly shout it all do the legs
yeah that's right
we'll see what other memes my producers
come up with next week well we are in
the midst of a lockdown pandemic they
have too much time on their hands just
everybody's very lucky they're not being
furloughed over this I'll see you next
time